land und brecht
[Musik]
richard freue mich zu sehen ja es geht
mir genauso mal leibhaftig mal wieder ja
du hast diese kette diese bräune weißt
du noch so diese spur tiefer ist als
diese normale braune die hast du im
gesicht so siehst entspannt und erholt
aus und so sagt dass gerade du kommst
aus afrika ja also ich finde dass ich
für afrika nicht besonders frauen
aussehen nein das ist doch dass du viel
an der frischen luft und ich weiß nicht
wie viel an der frischen luft und ich
war in afrika dort wo man nicht braun
wird im urwald im jahr im dschungel und
vereinigen im gebirge ja ich war bei den
virunga vulkanen und im bwin die reden
wollen und
die virunga vulkane vulkane sind allen
bekannt durch den fonds koreas im nebel
genau und so ist das auch ja also das
ist sehr sehr feucht kalt und neblig und
nachts wird zu 10 grad ok also nicht so
sehr um ein sicherer ist auch enorm ruf
und es ist enorm hoch also die virunga
vulkane sind so hoch wie die alpen das
heißt resultierend viereinhalb tausend
meter war okay also wo er dort na ja
genau nein ich hab da oben drauf aber
die
wo man da residiert ja und wo man sich
die gorillaz anguckt da ist man auf
zweieinhalb tausend meter fahren sind
das sind eigentlich dann verhältnisse
wie in ostafrika daher kenne ich das ja
auch so wenn du in ostafrika trainiert
hatte yao besteigt mir aber auch wenn du
jetzt irgendwie so ob dieser
ostafrikanischen hochebene da unterwegs
bist auch in äthiopien usw man merkt
dass da nicht so aber du bist wahnsinnig
weit oben also da wird es ja auch nachts
kalt und genau da aber hier ist es auch
noch wahnsinnig naja also gorillas im
nebel es trifft die sache natürlich
ausgesprochen gut und also in ruanda und
uganda im wald ja der heißt im panel
travel forest also undurchdringlich und
der ist auch noch so ja das intakter das
ist tatsächlich intakter dschungel es
ist ich viel wenn man sich die die
beiden nationalparks an guckt also
ruanda und uganda dann sind die nicht
wirklich riesig groß also das ist so 300
quadratkilometer der eine
und ich weiss nicht der andere
vielleicht 400 untersuchungen das ist
nicht viel ja das ist das bisschen rest
natur wasser übrig geblieben sind und
dass ruanda ist das bevölkerungsreichste
land afrikas das heißt also da wächst da
wächst ja also gezogen da ist ja ganz
klein wieder kleidern auf die kleiner
als nordrhein-westfalen aber mit über 16
millionen menschen wer nicht besiedelt
und das heißt diese
naturschutzgebiete sollen vergrößert
werden aber dafür musste dann auch
richtig die menschen alle umsiedeln weil
die bis an die grenzen überall natürlich
ihre war mir nicht klar das da capo an
da so dicht besiedelt ist ich habe dann
gesagt bevölkerungsreichstes land afrika
denke ich immer an ägypten jetzt eine
riesige bevölkerung hatten ja oder ja
ich meine ja sogar gerechnet auch wenn
von drei kilometern war es natürlich in
ägypten riesige gegner genau wisse ist
exakt ja und ruanda ist ein durch und
durch fruchtbares land voller voller
hügel und berge
sowie die schweiz afrika so sehr schönes
land wobei ich ehrlich gesagt kann da
noch schmeckt aber wir waren ja gar noch
spenden also unglaublich schönes land
ich war ja nun in vielen afrikanischen
hätten aber ich glaube ich habe kein
land gesehen das so schön ist wie uganda
war ich tatsächlich noch nie war mal
ganz nah dran ruanda wollte ich immer
mal hin ich weil ich das so interessant
finde ich habe vor vielen jahren mal den
wo war das denken australien glaube ich
völlig verrückt eine eine junge frau aus
ruanda getroffen die mir erzählte dass
ihre gesamte familie umgebracht worden
sein dies dann hat es irgendwie nach
australien geschafft
und hat völlig traumatisiert davon zwar
ein bisschen diese geschichte erzählt ja
auch nie wieder was von von ihr gehört
das war nur ein kurzes gespräch eine
zufällige begegnung und war dann und
deswegen war mir immer so nahe war dann
sehr
ehrlich gesagt ja
begeistert davon welche entwicklung
dieses land dann doch gelernt glaubt
vergleich versöhnung dann offenbar doch
möglich ist also man muss sich
vorstellen dass ruander so was erlebt
hat wie ein holocaust und das wort es
nicht zu klein also innerhalb sehr
kurzer zeit hat die regierung ein
genozid gelang geordnet befohlen und
durchgeführt
in dem zwischen
800.000 und einer millionen menschen in
ganz ganz kurzer zeit umgebracht wurden
und zum allergrößten teil mit macheten
kinder und die tutsis sind eine
minderheit von 9 prozent gewesen und die
hutu regierung wollte die komplett
auslöschen
und wenn man überlegt dass wir 90 er
jahren natürlich wurde bei uns in den
medien immer mal wieder darüber
berichtet aber doch nicht in dem ausmaß
wenn man sich überlegt was dort passiert
ist ja weil es eben in afrika war und
auch landesweit landschaft eine andere
war da man ja auch muss man auch sagen
man auch sagen also heute würde sich
ausgiebiger bericht ende aber trotzdem
ist das also man muss ja sagen dass das
schlimmste ereignis der letzten 50 jahre
in diesen unvorstellbar ja ich hab noch
ganz kurz gorillas das ist ja du hast ja
letztes mal erzählt nie in die augen
gucken ja final bis zum silberrücken
gekommen ja ungefähr 30 zentimeter
wirklich er es gibt eine regel man soll
nicht mehr als 8 meter während die affen
dann
aber diese regel ist dann sinnlos wenn
der affe auf dich zukommt da ist ja
keine ausweichmöglichkeiten du gehst ja
mit dem führer da hoch und der haut ja
mit der machete den weg frei und dann
stehst du auf irgendeinem morschen
baumstumpf inmitten von unterholz und
hat quasi einen halben quadratmeter auf
dem du dich bewegen kannst und wenn dann
der silberrücken auf dich zukommt dann
kannst du nicht weggehen abgesehen davon
dass du auch nicht weglaufen darfst weil
das also jeder der gorillas im nebel mit
denen den film über den fonds ii gesehen
hat weiß niemals weg laufen so und dann
bedeutete der der führer meiner
lebensgefährtin mir dass wir uns so
schnell wie möglich auf dem boden klein
machen sollten also dann quasi ganz
untergegangen ganz genau und dann
versöhnungs geräusche machen
wirklich ja ja und das fand dann auch so
angehen 30 30 cm friedlich friedlich
lieblos bedeutet das 30 zentimeter
entfernt von uns prix verstehen für
meine lebensgefährtin war das nicht so
bedrohlich weil der guten hat wirklich
keiner frau was im ernst man hat hier
versteht
sofort ich weiß nicht ob er das auch
nicht untersucht und so weiter das ist
vollkommen klar wirklich ja also
verändert wenn ich ihn darf auch nicht
übersehen
menschenaffen haben ja nicht die
lautsprache die wir haben nordkoreas
haben unterschiedliche laute aber die
kann man auf einer din a4 seite gut
zusammenfassen okay dafür sind sie
wahnsinnig gut in nonverbaler
kommunikation
das heißt sie deuten die
allerkleinsten zeichen ok und daran
erkennen sie auf dem ersten blick ob du
ein mann bist oder eine frau ja das
merken die an allem so jetzt haben wir
da beide gesessen und das ist als als
mann ist es wichtig nach ich bin 185 ist
es wichtig dass man sich klein macht wie
groß war
der geht ja nicht auf zwei beinen
gelaufen ist also da so fix aber nicht
zu schnell ja auf uns zugegangen wie
viele wenn die 200 kilo das ist also
schon sehr imponierend die sind wenn sie
sich aufstellen nicht so groß weil ja
die hinterbeine dich nicht durchdrücken
aber 200 kilo koloss ist natürlich schon
wahnsinnig beeindruckend ein sehr dicken
schädel und dann hat er dann neben uns
nur weile gerastet über schlägt das herz
das sind ja schon ein bisschen höher das
schon uns also ich würde sagen ich habe
in meinem leben schon mehr angst gehabt
weil es geht auch irgendwas bei alledem
das sanftmütige sven diesen tieren aus
also die ausstrahlung dieser tiere die
ist nicht so als wenn die ich jetzt ein
schwerkrimineller bedroht sondern es ist
was anderes das hat er fast ein bisschen
was müsste das irgendwo wäre naja und
dann ist hat also zwei minuten vor hart
bis er sich dann entschieden hat weiter
zu gehen was sonst schon ja also schön
im nachhinein ja und in dem moment sagen
wir's mal intensiv glauben ja faden sind
und gefährlich jetzt auch für den
gorilla oder potenziell nur für dich
frage jetzt wegen viren ja alle liste
muskelmann trägt das kk 11 12
der v2 maske was im regenwald wenn du
den anstieg mit deinen während du
bringst du irgendwas mit ihm hatte er
ein produkt das ist ja auch einer der
gründe für die acht meter abstand
das ist in der zweite grund ist einfach
diese gorillas sind an menschen gewöhnt
aber sie sollen ja nicht zu sehr an
menschen gewöhnen es dauert ungefähr
zwei jahre bis eine wilde gorilla gruppe
sich halbwegs an menschen gewöhnt hat
und es soll halbwegs bleiben jetzt
sollte sie nicht dazu kommen dass die
den osten zu dir kommen oridion stückes
machen oder so was soll dann bist du im
zirkus oder im so dann hast du ja keine
naturerlebnis genau oder west noch
betteln das sagen wir nicht passieren
also die uhr lassen müssen weiterhin in
ihrer welt leben und gleichzeitig keine
keine bedrohung darstellen und ungefähr
die hälfte der gorillas in diesen beiden
nationalpark ist auf diese art und weise
an menschen gewöhnten und die andere
hälfte nicht und so eine population ist
wie groß wie viele wittern nun ja das
sind so zwischen zehn und 30 tieren je
nach kraft und ausstrahlung des
silberrücken ja die die weibchen suchen
sich das ja also wenn ihr mit dem
silberrücken nicht so richtig glücklich
und zufrieden sind dann gehen sie
woanders stündlich jaja die verlassen
müssen sie auch schon aus genetischen
gründen ja sonst würde ich eine familie
immer noch inzucht betreiben und das ist
dann tatsächlich so irgendwann gehen die
weibchen weg und bei den männchen ist es
so manche bleiben da wenn sie sich mit
der rolle zweite geige anfreunden können
ja und wenn sich mit der rolle nicht an
die haben ja wo individuelle charaktere
dann da sonst schnitten sie die gruppe
und nehmen ihre ihre weibchen die ihnen
freiwillig folgen mit
es ist also die ausstrahlung die von
diesen
unglaublich friedlich
die die
reine vegetarier sind
jeden tag unglaubliche flächen wald
demolieren ja ein silberrücken fristen
35 kilo grünzeug war aber wächst
natürlich auch wieder
aufbrechen also man kann sagen nach
wenigen tagen sieht man die stelle nicht
mehr wo die gorillas waren
und
klimaveränderung dort ein thema ja also
ich bin ja jetzt eigentlich in der
trockenzeit a gewesen und die regenzeit
hat er schon eingesetzt es ist also dort
eher so dass es feuchter wird als
trockener und das ist auch ein trend das
ist noch nicht so mit letzter sicherheit
zu sagen war ersten quali thomas matter
es wäre jedenfalls nicht der
schlimmstmögliche trainer andersrum wäre
da sehr viel gefährlicher aber wir
wissen das ja ich meine die der der
klimawandel
verteilt die karten ja in 22 richtungen
genau also eine der großen bedrohung des
klimawandels besteht darin dass die
millionenstädte am äquator irgendwann in
die fluten versinken und es gibt gegen
den auf der welt regnet es immer mehr
und es gibt all die bekannten gegen in
deiner welt vor erste mal weniger inhalt
ich habe es jetzt im sommer in den alpen
gesehen im urlaub irgendwie auch in
südtirol bord wie die gletscher darunter
schmelzen des ist atemberaubend und
gleichzeitig hast du jetzt wird sich
dort thema diese dunklen schönen wälder
zum teil in den dolomiten
gadertal ganz berühmt ist ahlmann daran
führt das war ein ganz dunkles teils
jetzt plötzlich hell borkenkäfer braun
baumstümpfe
wir kanalisieren die natur ja und ja
also wir also der mensch macht in einem
ausmaß das klima ja das ist meine erste
marco sturm klimawandel ist es ja immer
so ist ja nicht so als ob man das alles
nicht wüsste ja ja aber es ist immer die
frage wo man gerade hinguckt menschen
begreifen ja nur was sie was sie
sinnlich erfassen
abstrakte dinge wenn ich sage 125000
tote ist das eine zahl ein toter macht
viel mehr mit dir als 425.000 also die
sinnliche konkret eine mutter die in du
siehst gelassen schicksal boden du
mitbekommen hast und so ist das mit dem
klimawandel ja auch und wir erleben ja
hat beim klimawandel auch
annehmlichkeiten im sommer werden wärmer
es gibt leute freuen sich drüber geht es
von oben können sich bis sogar gerade
darüber freuen und soja tropische
pflanzen gedeihen auf der terrasse naja
und und gibt die wirklich ganz harten
eines brutalen folgen die sehen wir nach
wie vor eigentlich im fernsehen ja wenn
in australien der wald brennt oder ja
oder russland ja aber wenn du das zum
beispiel so sie es dort immer wenn du
sie ist wie sich dann deine eigene
heimat so verändert plötzlich und da hat
wenig gereicht aber es war plötzlich der
perfekte sturm zwei winter mit sehr
nassem feuchten schnee stichwort
veränderungen des klimas in der unten
regnet es plötzlich im dezember oben
schweiz ganz feuchter schnee schneedruck
unfassbare mengen schnee bäume
umgeknickt wie wirklich wie wie
streichhölzer so und dann liegt dieses
buchholz darum und dann kommt ein sehr
warmer trockener sommer und dann kommt
das gleiche noch mal und dann ist
plötzlich dieser käfer da ich ja ich
habe uns werden hätten lehrer weiter
druck der käfer wird ja eigentlich durch
feuchtigkeit besiegt nach ja genau weil
der didi didi pelze designer rolf glenz
sind sicher sein natürlicher fall genau
genau und und das war dachte früher
immer den kann man irgendwie kaputt
grimaldi winter nicht kalt genug sind
aber der hält ja alles aus an kälte
richtig dass der nicht vertragen kann
dass ich so viel feuchtigkeit exakt um
diese feuchtigkeit fehlte und dann geht
er rein und dann ich habe mir das
angesehen das sind so winzig kleine
tiere und untergehen dann immer weiter
und immer weiter und irgendwann ist ist
der wald dann wirklich braucht das geht
in einer atemberaubenden geschwindigkeit
und ich habe
dieser tage mit mit hier anton hofreiter
darüber gesprochen über den wir auch
schon in unserem podcast häufiger
geredet haben er hat der dann in seiner
lakonischen art sagte er dem bolt ist es
egal
naja und und er hat recht er sagt dem
bald ist es egal bei der wald ist schon
im laufe der der erdgeschichte schon so
oft gestorben an verschiedenen
klimatischen veränderungen zugrunde
gegangen und erholt sich dann ja der war
im laufe seiner 501 teschner weil zurück
ich meine ich weiß noch was von südtirol
gesehen aber was er meinte ist weil da
es geht um uns es geht ganz schön weit
es geht um uns das ist der punkt ja wir
müssen nicht die erde retten das ist
völlig klar er also werden wir wir
müssen falls wir ein interesse daran
haben ich sehe dieses falls inzwischen
immer größer nun ist auch ja falls wir
ein interesse daran haben dass die enkel
und urenkel einen bewohnbaren planeten
vorfinden dafür müssen etwas tun
ansonsten wenn wir es aus der
perspektive der natur drehen kinder lust
mehr zum gegenteiligen ende kommt gebnis
kommen da müssen wir sagen die eher der
mensch verschwindet um so schneller
renaturiert sich der wald also dann
würde man die die welt ganz anders ich
habe gesehen gerade eben ist james
lovelock gestorben james lovelock war
vielen den 80er jahren so bekannt mit
seiner game hypothek er war irgendwie so
ein bisschen auch ein google der
esoteriker und james lovelock der über
100 geworden ist der der war ein
radikaler bio centrica das heißt er hat
die welt aus der perspektive des
menschen betrachtet sondern immer aus
der perspektive des planeten kino und
der der war zum beispiel begeistert vom
atomunfall in tschernobyl fall weil er
gesagt hat durch die durch die breite
zone die da entstanden ist kann die
vegetation zurückkommen bei der mensch
sich aus ihre weitgehend zurückgezogen
hat und ist auch hingereist und hat sich
was da angeguckt wie sich das entwickelt
hat und es ist ja auch so so und ein bio
centrica würde natürlich sagen je
schneller diese fürchterliche natur
experiment mensch vorbei ist umso besser
ist das für den planeten man kann sich
alles wieder wieder
einpendeln auf neu einpendeln nicht
genau wie vorher und natur immer so wir
haben ja keine gleichgewicht in der
natur sondern wir haben zeitweise
stabile ungleichgewicht ja und das wird
dann ein neues stabiles ungleichgewichte
entstehen so ist es ob das besonders
tröstliches für menschen die kinder
haben und irgendwann enkelkinder haben
wollen ist eine ganz andere frage ist
ich will diese perspektive hier auch
nicht zu stark machen aber ich will mit
dieser perspektive darauf hinweisen dass
alles das was wir hier tun wir für den
menschen ja ich für die er genau so
genau und dieser perspektivwechsel ist
wichtig weil es sonst immer so und es
wirkt so altruistisch unter der erde in
gefahr es ging es um die jagd nach geld
um uns es geht tatsächlich um uns aber
weißt du was das der gute überleitung
zudem zu dem thema über das ich mit dir
heute kurz sprechen wollte ich habe
gemeinwohl ja das sei nicht astronomisch
geht ja
gemeinwohl versus einzelinteressen ja
und das kannst du kannst du gerade
besichtigen in diesem land auf ganz
vielen verschiedenen ebenen ist aber die
die oberste ebene ich weiß nicht ob sie
das mitgekriegt hast in ruanda
wahrscheinlich nicht die masken
geschichte ja was affäre auf der der
berühmt gewordene flug nach kanada ja
das habe ich jetzt die reise landet
also sitzen alle darin die die ganzen
kolleginnen kollegen die journalisten ja
die mitreisenden kanzler reise der
vizekanzler ist auch dabei robert haben
fliegen nach kanada und dann dreht ein
hd kamera man das was wir so an text
bildern enya bericht im
morgenmagazin dreht ja so ein paar
schnittbilder damit du dann auf diesem
steht dann was erzählen kannst und jetzt
geht dieser schwenk durch dieses
flugzeug und keine maske und alles
schreit auf und sagt dir vollkommen
verrückt geworden das ist eine
unverschämtheit was für eine elitäre
abgehobene nummer ist das denn und wir
müssen dem nächsten jahr auch jetzt
gerade gestern beschlossen worden wir
müssen dem nächsten flugzeug nicht nur
wie der medizinische sondern auch fb2
masken tragen und die wogen der empörung
kannst dir vorstellen geht richtig ab
dann aber dann hat glaube ich schon
gesagt das wäre die regel jeder der mord
war musste ein negativen pcr-test hab
genau und unter diesen bedingungen gebe
es in regierungsflugzeugen osten ich
wäre auch immer gemacht hat thomalla das
ist korrekt war in ordnung gehen auch
formal alles völlig korrekt formal und
trotzdem ich habe genauso habe ich auch
argumentiert und dachte dann ja und
trotzdem kommt das unbehagen hoch und da
hat man genau dieses ding also was
dürfen die was dürfen wir wieso müssen
wie aber das war das argument warum
leicht benutzten ja so gesagt die tragen
auch keine massen dann habe ich das auch
nicht übrigens ich glaube ich weiß nicht
wie es überall in der welt aussehen aber
wenn du eine afrika fliegt ja mit einer
belgischen fluggesellschaft
da musst du auch keine maske tragen ich
weiß ist offensichtlich nicht
international überall so dass masken
tragen aber wenn die regel halten jetzt
in diesem land zum ja ist schon klar und
worauf du denn da ganz schnell kommst
und das ist eigentlich mein punkt du
sagst völlig zu recht formal alles
richtig und trotzdem ist es ein desaster
an einen kommunikations gau und vor
allen dingen du kannst das nicht
erklären weil auf der einen seite das
sonst dem motto wir machen wir leisten
uns dann sozusagen den toren pcr test
aber ihr müsst jetzt weiterhin schon mit
maske fliegen könnte man sagen 'du ich
dann kaufen noch einen pcr-test und dann
fliege ich gefälligst ohne ja so dass
man den leuten zur wahl stellt genau
entweder maske oder pc aber dann ist das
argument auch da wiederum nein dann
müssen es alle in diesem flugzeug machen
damit sozusagen die bedingungen dann
irgendwie so sicher sind ja das ist dass
das gegenargument
ich
fand es interessant weil
das ein thema von so hoher symbolik ist
und wenn du gerade wie jetzt in einer
situation in der es darum geht sozusagen
dem land echte zumutung zu verlangen und
zu sagen freunde jetzt müssen wir mal
die pobacken zusammenkneifen das wird
jetzt hart wie meine draußen ist viel zu
warm aber die frage was wird das für ein
winter die steht unmittelbar jetzt vor
der tür das wäre eine ähnliche
diskussion ja schon also ich will das
leben da seine pompöse hochzeit auf sylt
gefeiert hat ja auch viele gesagt haben
also mit seinen reden muss er sagen wir
wissen alle jetzt den gürtel enger
schnallen und es kommt den winter des
verzichts und so weiter ob das nötig ist
dahinter ist es natürlich auf der
anderen seite dass wir erwarten dass
politiker die besseren menschen sind wir
erwarten eine moralische vorbildfunktion
von politikern die wir wenn wir selber
politikern werden vielleicht auch nicht
erfüllen können ganz sicher nicht nur
deswegen ist die frage ob der anspruch
nicht auch zu hoch ja wobei also
christian linden das hochzeit um himmels
willen ich finde ehrlich gesagt das ist
privatangelegenheit und geht mit
überweiten vergleichbares aufregung ich
weiß aber das ist etwas ist tut mir leid
ich kann mich darüber beim besten willen
nicht aufregen das ist deren sache und
die wollten einen schönen tag und die
wollten heiraten und bitte das dürfen
sie dann auch das muss auch möglich sein
völlig in ordnung fand die bilder die
dabei entstanden sind zum teil
hitzig ja wie friedrich merz damit sein
flugzeug angeflogen kam und sonntag
griff trotz diesem flugzeug rausguckt
dass das hat er wieder was gab so
herrlich kolumne dazu eine glosse in der
in der süddeutschen zeitung also jemand
dann mal genau dieses flugzeug angeguckt
hat und sagt das war das hat den märz
cool gemacht wir da wenn er hinten
gesessen hätte er es uncool gewesen aber
weil er selber geflogen ist
wie auch immer kann man kann lange
drüber reden aber dieses ding ist
natürlich was anderes die dieses ganze
heikle thema sensible thema corona die
maßnahmen du merkst da draußen gibt es
große unruhe die leute sind einfach auch
müde die sind kaputt viele hechte
wirtschaftliche opfer gebracht und dann
sagen wir den leuten da gibt es dann
jemand wie karl lauterbach der sich der
mittlerweile wirklich leid tut weil er
ständig nur noch verprügelt wird es und
prügelknabe geworden jemand auf den
jeder eindreschen darf weil er nicht
müde wird zu sagen freunde wir müssen
aufpassen sonst vorsicht das tragische
und dann siehst du diese bilder dann
dasteht hat ihn so ein kontrast in
seiner rassen kontrast markus wir haben
ja auch schon mal viel darüber
gesprochen ich habe ja schon vor langer
zeit gesagt wie geht diese pandemie zu
ändern und wenn wir die große frage in
hunt ich mein verdacht war ja schon vor
langer zeit vor über einem jahr an
desinteresse
ja es ist stirbt an der sind
aber die pandemie gut vorbereitet das
sind zwei verschiedene das heißt wir
werden uns an die allgegenwart von
corona in bestimmten monaten besonders
stark in irgendeiner form gewöhnen und
das wird am ende passieren ja das kann
man auch wieder sagen man kommt aus
afrika und die leute die dort leben
neben keine malaria prophylaxe und die
leben mit dem tod nah und malaria ist
sehr sehr viel schlimmer noch als corona
und die können das auch nicht nehmen
weil du vergiftet sich ja auch wenn du
dein leben lang an malaria prophylaxe
machen würde ist wird sie genauso daran
zu grunde jedes der punkt das kann es
noch eine lieber gar nicht kannst du
kannst du gar nicht mal genau und ich
denke das ist mit corona ähnlich in
lauterbach hat sicher was sein damit die
zielperspektive vollständig recht aber
wenn die leute sagen im zweifel sei dann
ist es halt so menschen sind ja
unglaublich eingewöhnungs fähig jaja und
sagen ach ja und was gefieder und hier
dann und am ende gibt's noch einen teil
lockdown und wer weiß was dann alles
kommen denn die inzidenz zahlen dann
lassen sich auch mit dem mist leben und
jeder muss sozusagen wissen welches
risiko er eingeht ist ja nur eine frage
der zeit noch kannst diesen winter oder
nächsten winter etwas an weil es nicht
weggeht wir hätten die leute sich daran
gewöhnen man das ist sozusagen die
verzweifelte situation er als minister
versucht den schaden zu verringern
während eine wachsende zahl in der
bevölkerung sagt ja wir übernehmen die
verantwortung für uns selbst gemeinwohl
vielleicht machen wir nochmal du hast ja
auch ein buch zu dem thema mal gemachten
ist hat ja ganz ganz viele dimensionen
führen sollten uns mal der eigene folge
mal für vornehmen wir reden jetzt auch
so bisher über dieses ganze thema
doppelmoral und glaubwürdigkeit und so
weiter in dem zusammenhang anderer
aufreger oder anderes heißes
diskussionsthema grad und es geht den
leuten und gas umlage
plötzlich zahlen sozusagen
menschen für gas und energiepreise die
unglaubliche höhen erreicht haben
summen die am ende wem zugute kommen das
ist gerade die große diskussion ja also
wer profitiert sozusagen von dieser gas
umlage und warum müssen sozusagen alle
obwohl diese energiepreise die gaspreise
in den letzten jahren auch schon
dramatisch gestiegen das in teilweise
verdreifacht vervierfacht und jetzt
kommt das doch mal oben drauf sagt man
was auf jetzt müssen wir auch da wieder
alle die pobacken zusammenkneifen nutzt
jetzt leider nix wir müssen juni per
retten diesen und den großen gaskonzern
und so weiter und jetzt stellt sich
heraus nicht nur die profitieren zu
recht davon weil sonst hätten stadtwerke
plötzlich irgendwie kein gas mehr gehabt
dann wäre es sehr düster geworden in
deutschland
profitieren auch konzerne davon die
weiter von den fans integrierten einer
schieflage zu sein ja also konzerne die
in den letzten monaten gigantische
umsätze gemacht haben gigantische umsatz
sprünge gewinnsprünge gemacht haben
zwölf konzerne sechs davon übrigens
ausländische internationale konzerne
sechs davon deutsche konzerne wie alle
sagen brauchen wir eigentlich jetzt
nicht weil wir haben verdammt gut
verdient an dieser ganzen krise aber wir
nehmen es trotzdem wie findest du das
ich denke das ist kapitalismus also und
das funktioniert so ja ich meine die
diese großen konzerne werden sprich sind
ja wahrscheinlich zum teil
aktiengesellschaften bereich durchgängig
ja ja und als geschäftsführer bist du
deinen aktionären verpflichtet und nicht
dem gemeinwohl so und dass der konzern
das nimmt wundert mich jetzt erstmal
nicht ja das ist das einzige was was
passieren könnte wäre eigentlich das bei
der vollversammlung die aktionäre
hingehen würden und sagen wir nehmen das
nicht ich weiß nicht wie oft so etwas
schon vorgekommen ist in der geschichte
der rwe hat das gemacht rwe hat schon im
voraus gesagt wir verzichten darauf ja
wir machen das nicht ja das fand ich
sehr in ordnung ja und die anderen
brauchen noch ein gedankenanstoß bitte
so weit sind dass ich dazu sagen um
diesen preisen steigern wir unsere
gewinne nicht was auf da gibt es zum
beispiel axpo ein schweizer
energiehändler der seinen umsatz im
ersten halbjahr auf 6,2 milliarden
verdoppelt und den gewinn auf über 500
millionen euro getrieben im zuge dieser
gaskrise ja so viel geld in der schweiz
als systemrelevant sind zu 100 prozent
in öffentlicher hand übrigens auch
interessanter ist inzwischen kein
widerspruch ist kein widerspruch mehr
genau und sagen auf anfrage ich habe die
kollegen vom handelsblatt gemacht ja und
wir sind da jetzt also in sehr
geringfügige maß betroffen bei uns
geht's eigentlich gut heißt das
übersetzt aber trotzdem müssen wir diese
nicht gelieferte energie aktuell zu sehr
hohen kosten beschaffen usw unter nebel
das doch schön dass wir das in ordnung
dann gibt's v kannst du auch eine hör
mal früher mal mv österreich antwort
lässt sich daher der größte
österreichische energiekonzern welcher
richtiger ölmulti sehr erfolgreiches
unternehmen mittlerweile omv eines der
größten unternehmen österreichs
die haben mit ihrem öl und gas geschäft
im ersten halbjahr gewinn und umsatz
mehr als verdoppelt auf
500 milliarden euro bevor mir meine
moral sprechen mehr wir haben das
gemacht also wodurch haben die jetzt
ihre umsätze verdoppelt und auch ihre
gewinner einfach dadurch dass die die
die preise derart gestiegen sind her und
wer hat denn die preise steigen lassen
die gesetzmäßigkeiten der börse angebot
und nachfrage oder ja genau er ist hätte
ich gesagt wladimir putin hat sich
steigen lassen genau aber nicht allein
ja nicht allein nicht alleine also erste
auslösung ja genau ja und dann gibt es
diejenigen die gesagt haben
die russen drosseln die gas gerochen das
ist ja großartig ihn jetzt werden wir
fantastilliarden einstreichen und ich
meine bei all den appellen die wir in
letzter zeit gemacht haben ja an die
solidarität mit der ukraine und damit
auch die solidarität mit der politik
unseres staates zu sagen
wirtschaftssanktionen und das wird auch
für den ein oder anderen konsequenzen
haben ja heizung runterdrehen 3 beta
werden weniger behalten hallenbäder in
zukunft sicher auch und so weiter dass
man da eigentlich gar keinen so richtig
ganz großen aufschrei gemacht hat und er
sagen das kann doch nicht wahr sein ja
das hier trittbrettfahrer als
kriegsgewinnler so gut aber auskommen
und wenn es sich um aktiengesellschaften
handelt dann müsste es geht es ja nicht
nur um die ebene des der
geschäftsführung es geht ja um all die
leute die clever waren und gesagt haben
ich kaufe jetzt gas aktien ich kaufe
aktien übrigens auch rüstungs aktionären
und so weiter genau und das kann ja am
ende nicht sein dass leute mit wenig
geld in der tasche wahnsinnig hohen
gasrechnungen haben so eine andere leute
sagen auch noch die mehrheit steuerung
ist aber ich kann nichts besseres
passieren als die gastronomie
jahren verdient hast du von seiten der
regierung da mal so richtig
entscheidende vor schluss wäre
gesetzesinitiativen mitbekommen in den
ersten zwei wochen er dabei nicht da die
us voraus da bist du ja bei dem thema
der über gewinn steuert das haben alle
so ein richtiger kampfbegriff geworden
und das ist sehr interessant also es
geht darum sozusagen
greifen wir als staat wird in dieses
system in dieses marktwirtschaftliche
system ein und sagen macht da wo solche
gewinne gemacht werden die nur auf grund
dieser situation zustande kommen und
also außergewöhnliche überproportionalen
hohe gewinne die nehmen wir euch weg das
macht italien so das macht spanien so
das machen die griechen so das macht
england so das mutterland des
kapitalismus rängen ein leeres gemacht
beeindruckend ja ich finde ich auch ja
und anderen machen
der eingriff in die wettbewerbs ja wir
sagen und da kann man jetzt sagen aber
das war ja klar ist ferling die fdp die
sich dagegen wehrt dass christian
lindner dann sagt es gibt nur gewinne
oder keine gewinne ja aber es gibt keine
über gewinne was soll ja quatsch ja so
wer definiert was er über gewinn ist
aber ja auch recht kann man unter man
das definieren auch wenn sich land und
leute die sind aber auch so ein bisschen
willkürlicher unterwegs und jetzt würde
man immer sagen also die griechenland
zum beispiel jetzt würde man immer sagen
aber das ist doch unfair das ist doch
ungerecht wenn du dann aber auf der
anderen seite mal so tiefer ins
geschehen ein steigt wenn du auch mit
zb spd-vertretern sprichst wenn du mit
grünen-vertreter ansprichst die
öffentlich mittlerweile ziemlich
deutlich diese über gewinne steuer
erfordern aber im hintergrund sagen sie
dir naja wir müssen das schon aufpassen
ja es gibt rechtssicherheit in diesem
land ja es gibt ein system das wir
beschützen müssen weil sich unternehmer
investoren auch aktienbesitzer
häuslebauer die sinne von man kann ich
im nachhinein die regeln so genau genau
die verlassen sich darauf dass das das
regelwerk dieses landes ist und dann ist
das jetzt ebenso dann müssen wir damit
leben aber die frage ist die der moral
naja so erstmals die eine moralische
frage die darin besteht zu sagen ist das
überhaupt gut dass mit grundsätzlicher
energieversorgung in diesem land in
diesem ausmaß spekuliert wird es ist ja
so eine alte linke forderung zu sagen
das was zur unmittelbaren
existenzsicherung in einem
wohlstandsland notwendig ist damit
spekuliert man nicht es gibt also
wahrscheinlich gibt es sofort eine ganz
große einigkeit in deutschland und nur
wenige abweicht wir sagen wenn wasser
dürfen wir hier nicht spekulieren
beispiel genau deswegen spekulieren wir
mit wasser in südamerika und sorgt dafür
dass ja nicht so als ob wir das nicht
täten aber wir machen es den leuten
nicht verspekulieren nicht mit was aber
es ist eklig finden ganz gruselig jemand
wir spekulieren auch mit ernten wir
wetten auf ernteausfälle
kalkulieren mit weizenpreisen und so
weiter das wird ja alles gemacht und es
gibt ja seit langem eine initiative der
sagt mit diesen dingen ja spekuliert man
nicht die ganze zur grundsicherung wir
können mit tausend sachen spekulieren
aber damit nicht da würde sich die frage
stellen energieversorgung ja gehört ja
zu den staatlichen grundsicherung suiten
es ist sozusagen die die pflicht der der
öffentlichen hand dafür zu sorgen dass
ich ein warmes wasser aus der leitung
christen in deutschland ist das so und
elektrizitäts anschluss rast und sowas
und da ist die frage müsste da nicht
grenzen gesetzt werden also die über
gewinnen steuer und ich verstehe die
kritik daran die setzt so im nachhinein
ein heft jetzt so einem ukraine putin
bedingtes sonderregelung modelle und wen
wie nimmst du damit rein also ja
deutlich im turnier sah das und ab wann
geht das los ist die konzern dann wird
sie wieder abgeschafft
er gilt alles als kriegsgewinnler wer
gilt nicht dass das ist natürlich
juristisch wahnsinnig schwierig nehmen
die meisten unternehmen werden dagegen
klagen ja und so weiter das ist
wahnsinnig kompliziert aber wer meister
land stelle setzt untersagt hier das
spekulieren wir das gar nicht und ich
meine all diesen sektoren haben ja in
den vergangenen 25 jahren eine enorme
privatisierungswelle erfahren vieles
davon war ja viel stark an öffentliche
hand als es das heute ist wäre das nicht
am ende die richtige antwort auch da
wieder erster reflex immer zu sagen ja
wunderbar machen wir genauso ich bringe
den anderes beispiel tat interessant wir
sind jetzt gerade auf der suche weltweit
nach gas am besten lng flüssiggas
fracking gas was ist passiert in den usa
sind ganz viele dieser fracking
gasunternehmen während corona während
der pandemie sind pleite gegangen weil
der energiebedarf massiv gesunken ist
gibt es ja überall im land wird ja
gefragt an allen möglichen stellen und
in lousiana zum teil kommt das dann so
zusammen bitte verladen und so weiter
geht auch die umwelt dabei
teilweise vollkommen drauf katastrophale
zustände da
da am golf von mexiko aber
ist eine riesige industrie die in echte
schwierigkeiten geraten ist werden die
pandemie so jetzt kommt die frage
wie fährt man das jetzt wieder hoch und
überraschung es funktioniert nicht warum
nicht weil die ankündigung aus
deutschland wir brauchen jetzt allen sie
zwar erst mal aus sicht der investoren
und unternehmen eine gute ankündigung
ist ja würde sich lohnen
gleichzeitig schieben wir hinterher aber
nur für die nächsten zwei drei vier
natürlich so lohnt sich also für die
nicht mehr und es passiert nichts das
heißt du hebel ist sozusagen diese
marktwirtschaftlichen mechanismen hebels
du an dem punkt komplett aus und das ist
ein interessanter zusammenhang das muss
zu verstehen das heißt investoren
brauchen rechtssicherheit die brauchen
verlässlichkeit die brauchen langlaufen
der versöhnliche ladens ist keiner
bereit dieses geld in die hand zu nehmen
schlicht und ergreifend um das zu machen
und können uns auf und dann alles wieder
euer der unter der voraussetzung dass er
eben alles privat ist so genau und das
verstehe ich auch völlig warum soll ich
warum sollte ich versuche mein
geschäftsmodell wieder hochzufahren das
ist eine langfristige zukunft hat gibt
ein anderes total interessantes beispiel
kohlen wir fahren gerade wieder
kohlekraftwerke hoch was brauchen wir
wir brauchen schiffe die kohle
transportieren das ist sollte muss ja
immerhin auch
da kommen wir nicht in die gänge das hat
zum teil mit dem rhein zu tun er über
den nicht mehr wirklich transportiert
werden kann weil er so ausgetrocknet ist
das ist das andere drama aber das zweite
drama ist das natürlich diese ganzen
riesigen logistikunternehmen da ganz
genau hingucken ganz genau hinhören und
sagen sollten wir jetzt wirklich neue
schiffe in betrieb nehmen sollten wir
große investitionen machen um kohle zu
transpromo wir doch lange ruhig die
kontrolle wären wo sie uns sagen was auf
in zwei drei jahren wollten wir das aber
alles wieder ein wer solch freue mich
dass das ist das spannend ja das ist
gespannt in den 80er jahren meinst du
mit der ökobewegung losging da gab es
ein sänger kann man eigentlich nicht
sagen ich glaube dass lief unter muss
ich aber so richtig weiß ich das nicht
mehr der hatte einen karton ein
pappkarton ja und tippte immer mit dem
finger auf den pappkarton da sozusagen
seine musikalische untermalung und
erzählte die geschichte von irgendwo in
der südsee einem käfer der der
ausgestorben ist und zwar auch aufgrund
von menschlicher angeguckt und dann
erzählt er was als nächstes passiert ist
weil dieser käfer
verschwunden ist gab es da nur dann
gehen und den ernteausfall und soweit am
ende geht die welt unter
und also diese die supporter der das
aussterben eines einzigen käfer hat
einen solchen dominoeffekt ja und ich
glaube der letzte satz in dem in der
ballade war warum verdammt noch mal ist
bloß dieser käfer ausgestoppt so und
dann geht es also im grunde genommen
darum diese diese verkettung in der
natur und das gleiche was wir was wir da
haben ist nämlich muss man dazu sagen ja
solche ketten in der form in der natur
gibt es gar nicht das ist so ein
bisschen cryptome metaphysik ja das öko
fundamentalismus ja genau so läuft das
nicht aber egal das war jedenfalls hat
es damals großen eindruck gemacht aber
auf der gesellschaftlichen und
politischen ebene ja also der von putin
vom zaun gebrochene krieg mit all dem an
folgeerscheinung löst millionen von
folgen überall in der welt aus genau die
man sich überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen
und das bedeutet ja auf der einen seite
zu sagen wir müssen aus diesen
abhängigkeiten raus die globalisierung
hat eine schattenseite aber auf der
anderen seite zeigt ist uns auch aus der
globalisierung kommen
genau mein lieblingssatz von robert
musil lautet in der geschichte der
menschheit gibt es kein freiwilliges
zurück
und das kann man am beispiel der hohle
schiffe und einer deiner fracking
industrielle und material auch noch 1000
anderen beispielen aufzeigen man kann
nicht einfach mehr in heutigen zeiten zu
sagen wir reißen jetzt zur steuerung
anfahren in die andere richtung das geht
gar nicht geht auch sogar noch weiter
wenn du auch die frage zum beispiel
dieser über gewinnen da diese
kriegsgewinnler da gibt es ja danach
unternehmen also jeder würde
wahrscheinlich sagen moralisch völlig in
ordnung den rüstungskonzernen die jetzt
überproportional geld verdienen dann
nehmen wir das was sie zusätzlich
verdient haben und eigentlich gar nichts
großartig was dazu getan haben sondern
das ist dann quasi in den schoß gefallen
genauso wie
mineralölkonzernen ja
und das neben den weg aber was ist zum
beispiel übrigens mit freiwillig
aber das ist ja so klassisch liberales
argument es immer ja das tun aber
freiwillig kein zwang auch so soziales
jahr ja aber freiwillig jetzt drehst du
schon ich abbrechen da könnte man doch
unglaublich punkt möglich ja ja also
wenn wenn rheinmetall jetzt gewinn
milliarden spenden würde für die ukraine
ja im leben nicht schade eigentlich oder
wer aber glaubt nicht an das gute im
kapital
ich glaube ich glaube tatsächlich also
dieses marktwirtschaftliche system
dieses kapitalistische system speziell
dieser dieser satz diese soziale
marktwirtschaft das wird dir klar wenn
du dich mal intensiver mit diesen diesen
themen beschäftigt das ist eigentlich
schon ganz gutes system ja aber das ist
ja ein 1 1 was wir hier bei uns haben
ist
paternalistischer liberalismus in dem
begriff gibt es nicht habe ich erfunden
aber aber es ist tatsächlich so das
heißt der staat ja und das will auch die
fdp hat die fdp mache ja noch so würden
statt schon weil die finnen sich gehen
statt als schiedsrichter als anreiz
setzen als jemand der den den sicheren
warenverkehr gewährleisten der auch im
zweifelsfall einspringt und auch mal
unternehmen rettet usw
paternalistischer liberalismus dieser
paternalistische liberalismus ist auch
der der die maske vorschreibt naja das
ist sozusagen der vater der der sagt
kinder ihr können spielen was ihr wollt
aber ich gucke die ganze zeit zu und
wenn ich irgendwas schief läuft dann bin
ich zur stelle ja so ein bisschen von
oben herab und bissiger lucia mundt
dagegen gibt's ja sozusagen die die
gegenbewegung dazu ist der palio wie wir
alles uns ist im begriff den es gibt ja
ja ja der es ist im grunde genommen
palio liberalismus das in die tram
fehler die sagen staates verschwinden ab
hier hatten wir überhaupt keiner in
irgendwas einlassen das ist dieses
rollers wie man uns haben heiner geißler
hat immer gesagt wir haben kein
kapitalismus wir haben eine mischform
aus sozialismus und kapitalismus das war
jedenfalls seine feste überzeugung weil
der sozialstaat der kapitalistische
sozialstaat ein wohlfahrts netz und ein
paternalismus entwickelt hat der
weitergegangen ist als er ein
realsozialistischen staaten im sinne von
von renten
unfallversicherungen anteils ausfall
kurzarbeitergeld und soweit das sind ja
alles keine kapitalisieren zu den punkt
an dem du sagst das ist mir so hängen
geblieben eigentlich ist das
mittlerweile im verhältnis der staat als
dienstleister und du der bürger als
kunde das ist jedenfalls so die haupte
wahrnehmung wieder menschen gegenüber
der politik haben und jetzt kann es mal
zurück überlegen das hängt damit
zusammen dass seit wieviel jahrzehnten
sehr gut mal an die nicht anfangen
zurückzugehen wahlkämpfe über wohlstands
versprechen gewonnen werden ja wenn wir
an die macht kommen dann gibt es hier
wird die pendlerpauschale wieder
eingeführt oder das und das und so
weitere dinge macht und wenn man das als
staat sich so bewirbt dass man sagt beim
nächsten mal schenken wir euch wieder
was ist wieder weihnachten nichts was
ich unter kriegt er wieder geschenke
dann führt das natürlich dazu dass der
bürger den staat auch in erster linie
genau so wahrnimmt jaja als
weihnachtsmann und wenn der staat kein
weihnachtsmann ist dann ist der bürger
aber entrüstet und empört ja ja deswegen
deswegen traut sich ja im moment auch
keiner zu sagen wir sind ab sofort nicht
mehr der weihnachtsgeschichte sondern
man tut also wer einmal da war dass man
nur zumindest genau also andere kommt
nicht so richtig aus der weihnachten
immer nur laut 0 0 aber der sagt wird
hat immer kleiner ja das ist richtig ich
habe sagt ist immer wissen
und irgendwann kommt sozusagen ja
negativ sagt wirklich
mein sohn das ist also eine frage der
weihnachtsmann ja die kinder eher was
habt ihr mir mitgebracht
man ist nunmal so neulich darüber
unterhalten er sagt dem was total
interessante ist ja meinte papa weißt du
weil er system funktioniert nicht mehr
was meinst du und er meinte ja das
versprechen war immer
es ist für jeden genug da und zwar
deswegen weil der system immer gewachsen
ist
es wurde der kuchen wurde immer größer
deswegen konnte sich jeder egal wie groß
das stück des anderen war darauf
verlassen dass für ihn auch noch was
dann ja und damit aber jetzt kommt dir
einen punkt da wird der kuchen kleiner
und dann fängt man plötzlich an sich für
den kuchen des nachbarn zu interessen
und dann an sich haben ja genauso viel
kleiner geeignet so genau und sollte ja
da kommen wir auf einen elementaren
menschlichen mechanismus von da sind
nicht nur in deutschland so dass wir an
einem schrumpfenden volkswirtschaften so
jedenfalls in allen schrumpfenden
volkswirtschaften in russland zum
beispiel nicht die eine fairness
erwartung haben weil wir wissen ziemlich
gut aus falten experimenten der
wirtschafts ökonomien dass menschen
keinen angeborenen sinn für fairness
haben aber einen angeborenen sinn für
unfairness die ihnen widerfährt
das ist etwas was wir mit dem berühmten
kapuzineraffen teilen ja also das
berühmte experiment von frans de waal
mittlerweile 20 jahre alt kapuzineraffen
boten dressiert man hat spiel marken im
käfig geworfen wenn sie die wieder raus
reichten bekamen die entweder eine
weintraube oder eine gurke und aus der
sicht von kapuzineraffen schmecken
gurken so lala und weintrauben großartig
jetzt wussten die affen wenn sie die
marken raus reichten ja nicht was sie
kriegten und wenn sie die gurke kriegen
ja okay und weintraube war die freude
groß und dann wurde irgendwann die
gruppe geteilt und die affen im ersten
käfig wurden weiter mit gurken entlohnt
und die affen im zweiten käfig und mit
weintrauben endlich alle was dann ja
sofort stellt die affen im ersten käfig
die arbeit ein sie waren zwar bereit
gewesen ja für google am boden zu
arbeiten aber doch nicht unter der
voraussetzung dass jemand anderes für
die genau gleiche der lässigkeit
weintrauben oder
das teilen wir mit den kapuzineraffen
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht auf einem
gehen drauf aber diesen reflex zu sagen
ich kann mich einschränken zwar nicht
wer mein nachbar dass ich auch tue und
was meine und wir sind unglaublich
trainiert da hinten zu gucken was der
nachbar tut es mir natürlich in einer
wettbewerbsgesellschaft linien in einer
vergleichsweise schafften weil wir einen
kategorischen kooperativ in uns tragen
ja ständig zu gucken ja wie stehen wir
im vergleich zu anderen und deswegen bin
ich gespannt im grunde genommen wenn es
wirklich darauf hinauslaufen sollte ich
weiß nicht genau wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass wir im
winter deutlich weniger gas verbrauchen
in den privathaushalt in der industrie
dann machen wir ein sozial
psychologisches experiment
wie es das in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik jedenfalls noch nie
gegeben hat und du merkst wie groß der
respekt davor ist gab es jetzt hast du
wahrscheinlich nicht mitgekriegt aber
scholz hat ganz offensichtlich unter
umgehung sozusagen seiner
koalitionspartner habe glaube ich völlig
kalt damit erwischt
einfach kurz mal angesagt was auch wir
senken die mehrwertsteuer für für gas
insgesamt also wir packen auf der einen
seite diese gas umlage darauf und darauf
wird auch mehrwertsteuer fällig ja was
mich dazu riesige empörung geführt hat
aber auf gas insgesamt senken wir jetzt
die mehrwertsteuer weil wir wollen euch
da jetzt nicht zu viel zumuten also von
19 runter auf 7 prozent und auch da
wieder würde man reflexartig sagen
gut gemacht ja aber weißt was in meiner
angst wirst so
eine angst besteht darin dass das geld
in der kasse fehlt ja und dass das geld
gedruckt wird und wenn das geld gedruckt
wird heizen wir in gleichem maße wie wir
auf der einen seite erleichterung
schaffen die inflation an so und eigenen
die leute dann andersrum das ist das
eine und das andere argument ist und es
auch ein sehr interessantes argument du
hebels den preismechanismus mal wieder
aus auch da greifst du ins system ein
das heißt woher soll der anreiz kommen
für die leute gas zu sparen wenn es doch
billig bleibt nun ist es ja das ganze
hat ja noch so eine merkwürdige
dimension war ich ja gas sparen
eigentlich gut finde ja ich finde ich
finde auch sich damit abzufinden zu
sagen es wird vielleicht in zukunft in
deutschen wohnstuben zwei grad kälter
finde ich zumutbar
also ich sag das in dieser klarheit weit
ich fordere das schon ganz ganz lange
allerdings hat ja das mit dem krieg in
der ukraine noch gar nichts zu tun
sondern einfach deswegen
weil wir aus ökologischen gründen sehen
müssen er hat dass wir unseren
lebensstandard eine einen oder anderen
ecke dass wir den runterfahren dass wir
weniger energie verbrauchen weniger
energie zu verbrauchen bei 40 jahre lang
eine zentrale forderung der grünen es
gab auch immer einsatz unter den grünen
zu sagen energie ist in deutschland so
günstig
weil das eben dazu führt dass die leute
wie bekloppt heizen und so weiter und
die fenster aufmachen und der ganze co2
ausstoß der damit verbunden ist und so
weiter also eigentlich können wir ja gar
nicht mehr so weiterleben deswegen finde
ich wird dieser winter ja auch deswegen
ein interessantes sozialexperiment ist
das
grundsätzlich zumutbar oder ist es
grundsätzlich unzumutbar und solcher das
ergebnis heißen es ist grundsätzlich
unzumutbar dann würde das auch bedeuten
dass wir aus unserer verschwendung
gesellschaft nicht rauskommen was ist
deine prognose
ich persönlich glaube es wird ähnlich
sein wie in der fanny das heißt ich
nehme an der größere teil der
gesellschaft wird sich daran gewöhnen
man muss ja auch ganz ehrlich dazu sagen
nicht jeder wird darunter leiden wir
müssen ja eigentlich die frage stellen
wie ist das mit geringverdienern und
leuten mit sehr wenig geld die ihre
gasrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen kann
denn wir reden ja nicht über leute die
viel geld haben und die sich ein
bisschen ärgern und sagen mein gott da
wird ja immer teuer und das war's na das
ist ja nicht ganz unerheblicher teil in
diesem land den pass ghanas hat gar
nichts ausmachten sondern die frage ist
was es mit denen denen es richtig was
ausmacht und ich meine gute ihre
regierung wird sich das eine oder andere
ausdenken um
dem tumult und und und den härtefall zu
verhindern aber ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass die fdp so übliche
verdächtige von so etwas profitiert aber
ich glaube ähnlich wie bei corona nicht
dauerhaft und auch nicht es wird zu
keinem mehrheitsfähigkeit führen das
glaube ich nicht also ich glaube sie
wird zu einem zeitweiligen auf
weltkriegen und das wird dann wie immer
ab
ich glaube das amt das wird eine tiefe
krise und deutschland verliert gerade
wirklich wohlstand und ich dieses dieses
geschäftsmodell deutschland ist im
moment steht wirklich zur disposition
das funktioniert es so nicht mehr wir
haben sozusagen billige energie aus der
eine diktatur importiert und exportieren
unsere waren in die andere diktaturen
und machen uns sozusagen auf zwei seiten
abhängig das ist dieses geschäftsmodell
deutschland mein gefühl ist und das sage
ich als jemand der irgendwann in dieses
land gekommen ist und da vielleicht
immer noch so einen anderen blick drauf
hat dieses land kann unfassbar viel wenn
es darauf ankommt und die leute sind
unfassbar diszipliniert um sind
unfassbar stark und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dieses deutschland wird
stärker aus dieser krise herauskommen
was ist reingegangen ist
hundertprozentig also mit den schönen
worten könntest du dich bei der nächsten
ich danke dir sehr nicht ja auch war
sehr
nochmal das geräusch
eine produktion von mpeg 2 und podcasten
er im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]